hey what's up Jerry Ferrara and I am
here to answer the internet if you could
pick one celebrity to be your wingman at
the bar who would you pick ah I'm gonna
pick Kevin Hart because Kevin Hart
legitimately is one of the funniest
people I ever met also in social
situations that dude is just on point he
works a room Kevin Hart that's a easy
one I didn't say that
would you rather prove aliens are real
or proof ghosts are real
I would rather prove aliens are real cuz
I don't know I just feel like that's
talked about way more and with their
like storm area 50 I just feel like that
it's very current and good to go I'd
much rather prove aliens are real yes
you get offered a billion dollars to
never leave the state of Ohio do you
take it
hell yes absolutely by the way you can
get me from much less much less well I
also might have a little chip my wife's
from Ohio
I have infrastructure there I'm set up I
got family friends I'm set up if every
time you finish sex a song played which
song would you want it to be oh man
genuine pony that's like I guess people
use that one before is that like a
common answer I just feel like I'm even
more so for just the rhythm but it could
also be like the sixties like I'm sorry
like apologetic for bad performance very
possible would you rather be bald by the
age of 20 or five three with the full
head of hair that's interesting because
I am NOT a very tall guy and being short
has not really affected me or bothered
me I'm I'm gonna go I'm gonna go bald by
the age of twenty because I feel like I
got a decent shaped head shave it and I
love basketball so I feel like the extra
3-4 inches of height I have over five
3-wood is like a real thing I could
theoretically post up someone who's five
three like give me the ball yeah it's
backing down
would you rather never be able to eat or
drink Wawa
Sports aah I'm gonna go with like I have
to eat cuz if I don't eat I just like I
really I like pass out and stuff III I'm
gonna drinking I could live without I
guess how long would it take you to eat
a whole grocery store I think I could do
it in a year a year but like just think
about the grocery store like there's a
lot of I'll space that's not anything
that's edible
you know just the food in the grocery
store I think a year I think a year on
the shelves we're not talking about like
what's in the back and storage on the
shelves am I allowed to have people over
for dinner in like just me all right two
years two years I I amend it would you
rather only watch softcore porn or minor
league sports for the rest of your life
I like my league sports I would take my
league sports any day I'm a fan of minor
league sports I like a good underdog
story when they get called up it's great
minor league sports all day who wins in
a street fight Allen Iverson or Yao Ming
ah I'm gonna go with Allen Iverson I
feel like yo Ming's height would work
against him in a street fight Allen
Iverson there's the low center of
gravity
I'm gonna go AI would you rather always
wear shoes that are one size too small
or close the other one size too small
ah that's tough I'm gonna I'm gonna go
with the shoes one size too small I feel
like you could kind of toughen up your
foot your foot will be able to handle
you have one free throw shot if you make
it you get 1 million dollars if you miss
it you could never text again do you
take the shot
absolutely finally I'm definitely
hitting it but that is that is a bet
worth taking the risk reward is well
worth taking and let's make the money
alive 10 10 million can never play video
games again one shot where you wanted me
to say [ __ ] it like I'm not
Malthus I'll need the money but I need
to put my videogames are you taking
because inherently what you're saying is
like you I would I would I pay ten
million dollars to play video games for
the rest of my life that's like the
inverted vote my lot to watch video
games being played so I'm taking the
shot I'm going for the 10 million yeah
yes but that's a lot of it's a lot of
pressure man I'd love to see someone
shoot a free-throw under those
circumstances who's the celebrity you
most want to see in a sex tape all right
this is not me ducking this answer true
story I don't think we I think sex tapes
need to be finished don't think we need
them it's been done like what I just
don't think we need a man I'm out
there's so much other forms of
entertainment though dude like Michael
Eastwood's go watch yourselves oh my
league's worth if you could party with
one sports team in history who would it
be
you are gonna like this answer no and
this goes against what my fandom would
say but I read this book once and it was
a really good book it was called when
the bad guys won and it was about the 86
Mets I don't know how much of the book
is true well I know as those dudes won
the NLCS and according to this book they
destroyed the plane on the flight back
even if that book is 50% true too to be
a voyeur and like watch all that 86 Mets
Oh see I'm more like like I'm gonna be
like the kid from almost famous like I'm
gonna party a little but I'm more just
gonna be like lean back and right watch
you know and like document